[Music]
hey guys welcome to another episode of
conflamibation no
hey guys welcome to another episode of
[Music]
complamination
[Music]
you know what i usually wear a t-shirt
or i usually wear
a long sleeve or a hoodie it gets
super hot it's the summer time
wanted to wear a t-shirt decided to
spruce it up decided to spruce it up
so i put on a shirt that buttons down
with
some [ __ ] flowers on it you
understand me so there's
literally no stopping me now
okay i got on a vacation shirt and i'm
just
lounging like chuckles from gi joe for
some reason that guy was in the army but
got to wear the hawaiian shirt
and i remember that and chuckles was my
favorite character
uh but i'm chilling dude i got this kind
of open a little bit it's nice my chest
hair peeking out can't really see
because the microphone's blocking it but
it's all good
your boy's got white hair in his beard
and still only like two pieces of white
hair in his hair
so what hap dude i'm still
riding the buzz off last episode dude
horizontal in his [ __ ]
was [ __ ] dude it was
disgusting the way it did it it was
disgusting how many clicks and slams and
likes it got do it by the way man if
you're a fan of this
let me actually talk about that later
right now
i'm still riding high
off of number one the last episode but
also more importantly
riding high off of my friggin workout
dude
[Music]
the teardrops are coming in dude the
teardrops
my [ __ ] hips are
in an absolute hysteria
you understand my hips family
just died careening off of a cliff
in a 2007 volvo because
they're just [ __ ] crying man i mean
dude the quads the quads is really
coming in
they really are and i'll tell you what
it's gonna look goofy
do you think i'm not serious it's gonna
look goofy
when my quads really pop out it's gonna
look goofy
because i've got small knees my shit's
gonna look
boom ting boom my legs are gonna be like
big
ants two big ants that just jut out from
under my [ __ ] hips
i'm [ __ ] ant man dude i'm ants man
two ants man just [ __ ]
and crazy about thing about ants is they
can lift like what 900 times their body
what the [ __ ] man yeah but i seriously i
go to this [ __ ] coffee shop and
uh i go every i go all the time and and
lately they were just like i heard them
mumbling i said what's up and they're
like chris you got to get new shirts and
i'm like huh what's going on they go
you're busting out of them
and i say all right so i got one that
buttons down but it's all good do it but
it's
it's it's you know and i did what did i
do for a workout today
i [ __ ] trekked uphill 45s in both
hands
200 lunges ah [ __ ] man
i'm sorry strong guys
oh man i [ __ ] trekked uphill it's
like this steep
and i did one leg after another just ah
[ __ ] strong guys there's a new guy in
town
oh [ __ ] strong guys so your boy is just
taking steps holding weights like
there's some cookies just chilling
like he's got a sacked lunch like he's
got two [ __ ] sacked lunches
for both of his kids only they're not
that because they don't have [ __ ]
lunchables in them
they've only got weight and he's
trekking up the himalayan
he's trekking up the himalayan street
that's what he's doing
and his hips are [ __ ] crying dude
so anyway my [ __ ] hips parents
careened off a [ __ ] mountain
[Laughter]
he's got small knees but packed around
it is some [ __ ]
type tight wound muscle uh can't jump
for [ __ ] though so
it's all good i did that and then i just
was like is that enough and i was like
no and i kept going
oh i kept going i was like was that
enough most guys would have been like
stop
okay but okay going i'm sorry strong
guys
so yeah i'm [ __ ] feeling good man um
and uh we have a good time on this
podcast and i make sure of it i make god
damn sure of it
i haven't checked the numbers on the
podcast
for a while when it comes to
just the listening part i look at the
youtube views
but guess what dude we're moving up
yeah dude we're [ __ ] moving up
so it's all good dude and that's amazing
dude i'm also trying to get 20
pull-ups in a row can't can only get 19.
barely barely i could get 18. i can get
18 honestly i can get 18.
but now i can [ __ ] and i'm telling
you so you can hold me
work out accountable dude so i can
[ __ ]
y'all thought i did this y'all thought i
did this
y'all thought i did this i do
this kristen don't hit the camera it's
imperative
you don't hit the camera the whole thing
shook all good
love you but you hit the camera now
are there technical difficulties are we
okay guys it was important though
because she had to grab her [ __ ] ipad
great great can't hear myself all right
so look we're getting off to a rocky
start i wanted to talk about my workout
and now we're back
don't have coffee it's fine drink way
too much coffee today
i drank way too much coffee today it's
fine um
so yeah man look just [ __ ] put a
blazer on that like button
and put some pants on that subscribe
button and for that bell notification
put a [ __ ] give it a sweet tiara and
just dress up those buttons dude
dress up that like button dress up that
subscribe button
and dress up that bell notification i
will tell you this i feel like because
uh the uh i don't even know what you'd
call them the similes no the [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] i'm talking whatever
i'm saying about these like buttons
because i don't want you to smash them i
want you to dress them up
i want to have fun with those like
buttons that's what i want you to do but
i feel like because i do that and don't
talk about it like a normal youtube guy
i feel like we're kind of missing the
point here and i feel like maybe you're
not liking and subscribing so i'd like
to
actually take a uh a full uh
serious sentence out of the uh
congratulations podcast right now
and just say hey guys like and subscribe
on the on the pomcast
couldn't do it couldn't do it and it
won't do it
because i'm here for you dude i'm not
gonna just
you know i'm not a hooker you understand
i'm just here
to be real and i can't not be real so
um you know
johnny learns a lot and he's good he's
[ __ ] learning he you know he learns
about tylenol
we got twitch out there we've been on
twitch we have a good time it's actually
nice to be on twitch
uh uh you gotta join us over at flex
avenue
uh i'm talking about uh with with uh
with kristin
i was playing video games i was
streaming video games and uh it's pretty
fun so going over to flex avenue and
also that [ __ ] lime green merch just
[ __ ] we got a whole nother shipment
in it
dude it's just so it's sick with it you
know
it's sick with it so to go to
crystalline.com we got the socks dude i
got
[ __ ] shipped nine pairs of life rip
socks
and it's so sick with it dude and
[ __ ] and and ivan gets rid of came
over
and i had nine [ __ ] pairs of socks
and kristen said why don't you take one
and i didn't authorize her to do that
but i've got nine pairs
is that enough i don't know dude but now
we're all sick with it
um so let's talk about stuff man i just
kind of been bullshitting a little
lately and we didn't really get into the
[ __ ] meat and potatoes of the podcast
because you know this is
the [ __ ] meat and potato podcast um
i've been feeling okay i've been feeling
good lately you know um
i was uh you know
i was with calvin all day he's been
really [ __ ] cute and really sweet
it's sweet to watch these dudes these
little dudes and little
you know these little children grow man
he was sharing at the park
he had a [ __ ] stick and he just
looked at it and he gave it to the
little girl and the girl goes
thank you and it puts it behind her back
and calvin was like where'd it go and
she didn't tell him no that's that's
their family's business you know you
need to
probably educate your children a little
bit uh you know
just maybe be like look we share
calvin shared with you so what's what's
going on here right
like i'm not in the mafia but i do
believe an eye for an eye my son gave
you the stick
so now that the stick is behind your
your son or daughter and she's
pretending like she doesn't know where
it is
and calvin is only 17 months so
do me a favor why don't you grab that
stick from your daughter and give it to
calvin
sir i don't want any trouble why don't
you screw you know as i grab his [ __ ]
like this why don't you grab okay sir
sir
sir sir
[ __ ] all of a sudden um
so yeah but uh so he took him to the
park and he shares and it's awesome he
shares my son is
sensitive dude it's so beautiful man
it's so beautiful
he just you could see him really
focusing on stuff and he's just like
really taking stuff in and then like
he he went to go give we'll be like
share calvin and he'll go to give it to
somebody and then if the person doesn't
see him do it
he'll like look back at us and he'll be
like what do i do now
i i try to do it and they don't notice
me do i disappear
is life over now do we start over from
the stage won't
um it's cute as [ __ ] man
it's so awesome having a [ __ ] hello
baby
i love him he's a toddler now which is
crazy dude
um but he doesn't have a [ __ ] clue
that his mom and dad are in a fart war
um
the uh he was the doctor came over to
the house
and uh since the pandemic we we
were like we're not going to the [ __ ]
thing we got the doctor to come to the
house and so the doctor came to the
house the other day
uh and the you know
she was like you had to give him shots
and [ __ ]
and then they had and then he was like
crying
and it was like all pandemonium
and then we wanted the i ordered
ubereats at the same time
and the driver just had no idea where my
house was
dropped it off at another address so i'm
like you know how your boy gets your boy
gets hot
your boy gets super hot when that [ __ ]
goes down you've got a job to do
my [ __ ] address is on the curb it's
bright white i just had it done
and the the uber guy said
yeah i called him up before i even went
down i was like i don't know where this
food is and
and she's like it's calvin's crying
she's like just relax and i'm like yeah
no i know but but the food i don't know
where the [ __ ] it is it says it was
dropped off
and it says thanks for the tip like it's
[ __ ] so shitty it's all thanks for
the tip and the food's not even [ __ ]
there
so i'm like all right so i don't know
what to do so i got to go find this food
so i call i'm i got
i got to leave and and look for the food
i got to walk outside look for the food
and and and kristen's like nervous about
something because the nurse is calling
the doctor and when the nurse calls the
doctor
and there's only the nurse in the house
and they're like why the nurse called
the doctor what's going on and then
kristen looks at me
and she says something's wrong and i'm
like what
what's wrong she said something's wrong
and i'm like what do you mean what's
wrong
not the uber [ __ ] like with our kid and
she said she looked at me
and she actually said his head's smaller
and i said smaller than what she said
it's smaller than it was
rage
rage i have to deal with
two things now the uber guy
is dropping food off all willy-nilly
and now i have to deal with my wife's
hypochondria
i gotta tell i am it's one of those
moments
where you're like okay guess i'm gonna
have to say this ridiculous sentence
because i had to say it i looked at her
and as calmly as i said as i could i
said sweetheart
nobody's had ever get smaller
now let me go find out where our [ __ ]
breakfast burritos are
and i was so angry because i didn't want
to [ __ ] but it was just too much for
me to deal with you know sometimes you
let that anger get it just
bubbles dude and you just it's god's
just like
let me toss you another one i'll toss
you another one you get all these
today you get all these stones today and
you're just like nah come on god no no
and i'm like look out and do my favorite
thing
to do to the ubereats guys because they
can't have how many times do they find
your place
how many times did they find your place
for me it's [ __ ] 40
of the time i gotta go out there and
have like a [ __ ] airplane flag
or some [ __ ] or one of those or no the
the [ __ ] lit up ones like the really
short lightsabers that the [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass guys have when they're trying to
land the planes in fog
or those they're just creeping on a come
up dude they're just creeping on the
[ __ ] hill
and i'm like bro i do lunges up this
hill faster than you drive
look at the numbers
and the dude i was nowhere i look up i
look down
nowhere in sight so i [ __ ] call the
guy
and i say hey man where is uh the food
and he says i dropped it off
and i said no uh cause it's
it's not at my door i'm looking at it
right now and i say the
the address and he says the same address
i said
except for one number is different
now if you drop a uh
uh if you're looking for an address and
one number is different
you could be anywhere else
you could be anywhere [ __ ] else
i looked at both my neighbors one there
depending on the number two it could be
really far away
the number he got wrong wasn't the last
number it was the second to last number
if it was the third to last number or
aka
the second number i would have [ __ ] all
over the road
if it was the first number i just would
have moved to the new place
but um he says no it's this place and i
say i'm not gonna say my address but say
it's like one two three four
he says yeah i dropped it off i said one
two three four he said no one two four
four and i said it's one two three four
and i screamed it out
and he came and then he drove up
and i already had gotten the thing from
one two four four or whatever the [ __ ]
and then i
and then i say and then i say look at
the [ __ ] thing it's bright right here
it says on the ticket i let my anger get
the best of me dude
and i feel bad i feel bad i actually
feel really badly
i i truly actually feel badly and i i uh
i want to apologize to that guy he
i don't know if he [ __ ] i don't know
if he listens to this podcast
psych we're moving up
so uh we're you know we do it
but we have a good time but your boys on
vacation look at this
dude kanye west you know take that
[ __ ] thing off your
face how about that
hey take over dude the [ __ ] thing
his bedroom
in mercedes-benz stadium since he's
living there to finish up the donda
album
first of all danda what is it
oh it is oh that's sweet i like that
that's cute oh i love that
i'm gonna call my next special ellie
that's cute i love that she died right
of uh
some kind of surgery so sad no
can't really make fun of kanye can i
well [ __ ] myself there didn't i
nah but take the red thing off your face
it is cool it is monochromatic
great went from uh making fun of him in
a light mood
talking about his dead mom to now i'm
jealous of the way he is monochromatic
y'all think we all y'all y'all think we
still get in the project next week
power 106. bro he'll just dude
he did the listening party or whatever
it was in like a whole stadium
and he did he not say anything just
weird
weirdness and here's the other thing too
because he's very talented
but people will now be like oh gotta be
weird to be talented
and just [ __ ] up the whole game they've
been doing that by the way
people think just because they're weird
they're talented
kanye's sending the wrong message out
there damn that's sweet he
named it donda that hits me right here
dude
head smaller
i watched ice road that movie with liam
neeson because i had to because liam
neeson is in it
i'll tell you right now one thing i
noticed in ice road and that i think i
noticed before in other liam neeson
movies
but i wasn't equipped to understand the
magnitude or
idea of it because sometimes your brain
births an idea and sometimes you don't
realize
until you fully understand that
that idea was already
given birth before you even thought
about it
do you understand what i'm saying i
thought i thought of something
and then i realized it's a truth it's
out there
and what i'm about to tell you
is the idea and the truth liam neeson
has the sexiest nose out of any man i've
ever seen in my life
that's it wrap it up we should go so
podcast is over so it's all good so we
figured it out so anyway let's
let's pack up and we should uh we should
probably get out of here
how can i go up from there liam neeson
has the sexiest [ __ ] nose out of any
not only action movie star any male
there that i've ever seen that's it we
should all right let's back up
let's back up we got to go we've figured
it out we figured out
we did some real work here on this
podcast let's go
have you seen it it starts
in the middle of his forehead
his nose starts here
strong it's like a fist that just pops
out of his forehead
and then just goes straight
down at an angle of like i'd say
whatever that is because i'm not a
mathematician and it
stops in the middle of where
a nose and a mouth should be and though
that's where his nostrils are
and it's so [ __ ] strong it's just
basically two fists
and it's so sexy dude and i'm man enough
to say it
liam neeson's nose you talk to anybo
here's the deal
you talk to some guys that'll be like oh
how can i tell i'm not gay i can't
do take those guys out of the equation
those guys i don't understand
when guys are like what am i gay i can't
tell if a guy's good looking one time i
asked my friend
oh yeah is that guy good looking i don't
because i didn't me i was like yeah
what's his deal was he tall is he good
looking he's like i don't know if he's
good looking
i was like what do you mean he was like
gay i'm not attracted to guys
he's like bro what are you talking about
you know if a guy looks like
cool or if he's like hello
with a like bringing a [ __ ] slushy
that's an
ugly dude i brought my own
uh snacks to the movie
like that guy's ugly as [ __ ] but if you
look like
[ __ ] you know what i mean if you got
your vacation shirt on your hair quaffed
back
and you're looking at literally no one
and you're a tall drink of water then
oops oopsie daisy
you're good looking
that's why i gotta practice not making
eye contact bro cause i gotta get
sexier you know
what would you say just looking what do
you say
they're right here what's that what are
you saying what are you saying
so you know take those guys
out because i don't believe in those
guys
all right at all
you're out i don't know if you're
homophobic or what it is
those guys are gone you take a check
and she's like i mean yeah it's all
right you know
she lying what is it what
what about the two-fist thing look he's
got two fists and they just come out of
it they stop
there's a big nose and hey you know
she lying it's all good but you know
that now
the reason why i knew in this movie
versus other liam neeson movies
that he had the sexiest knows of all
time was because a lot of the time the
camera was in the passenger seat and he
was just driving so you get to see a
nice profile shot of liam neeson
and that [ __ ] [ __ ] knows dude he is
just
that [ __ ] nose is fire
i've got a dick on my face
the problem is you don't think i'm sexy
and i'd agree with you except for one
thing
i'd like you to take a look in between
my eyes
above my mouth and below my hairline
what is that before you answer
no it's not two fists
get a little lower get in a horse stance
look up do you see those two saucered
holes
no no no no exactly
if i breathe out right now you'll die
if i breathe out slowly you'll die
slowly
if i get in a horse tents too
you'll disappear into my nose
walk away do it quick because i'm going
to turn my head
and if i do and you're not fast enough
you'll get hit with my [ __ ] nose and fly
off that cliff
dude i love this podcast
that's it
you know i love it i get to talk about
leave me some nose for 20 [ __ ]
minutes and you guys just
listen and npr's out there like well you
know technically you got to
yeah you're not sure in space and time
continuum and [ __ ] every time i turn on
npr
the funny thing about the space and time
continuum what the [ __ ] is that dude i
googled
space time the other day i i swear to
god i
real i was like i got to know what it is
i'm 41 i got to know what space time is
okay it can't just be something that one
of my friends says too much i have one
friend
that says it way too much everybody has
the one friend that says space time too
much
and you're like dude all right but how
about this
i want to learn i want to be a better
person so maybe i am the problem maybe i
should look up space time
and maybe i should understand what space
time is now i'm just a lowly comedian
podcaster
right i'm not even a [ __ ] i'm not
even close to a scientist i don't even
know one scientist
so i was like let me just google
spacetime you could google everything
that's on me if i don't know what a term
is
that's on me you could understand it and
as my mommy says
i'm smart so i googled space time dude
11 minutes okay i give up
i give up dude you got me internet i'm
done i tried for 11 minutes i actually
tried less than that i tried probably
for like six minutes dude
i'm out man i read space time over and
over again
i googled it i looked at websites i
watched videos
dude i'm out if something's that
confusing bye
bye if something's that confusing
see you guys later
out of the [ __ ] airplane pop the
shoot
me me after i [ __ ] bail from looking
at space-time
playing on fire zipping by me
a bird just smacks me in the face me
after i look up space-time for six
minutes dude i don't know what the [ __ ]
it means
look up look at the the [ __ ]
definitions that they have for space
time just let me let me look it up
and let's try to understand this
together dude
space time look at this i'm googling
space time all right
space time noun physics noun space time
i don't know why [ __ ] dictionaries
always do that by the way you look up
car it'll be like
noun car car car noun
automobile car car and you're like i
already know what the [ __ ] i'm looking
up
oh really carmen's car
it's so stupid and you know what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about
i'll look up lebron lebron lebron the
brawn
french for the brawn um
here it is space time the concepts of
time and three-dimensional space
okay okay the concepts
of time first of all what the
flying [ __ ] house are the concepts of
time
do you mean time
stop being so cock-sucky when you're
right in the [ __ ] dictionary dude
narrow it down
the concepts of time dude imagine you're
at a dinner and somebody just says
well you know the concept of time you
would [ __ ] take a plate of potatoes
and make them go vertical
you'd be like oh did you just say did
you excuse me did you say concepts of
time yes
by any chance do you like vertical
potatoes
they'll say no but i just want vertical
potatoes all over your face
the concepts of time and
three-dimensional space
regarded
[Laughter]
has to be the stupidest [ __ ] thing
i've ever said in my life
like like checking with the guy excuse
me sir
do you happen to like vertical potatoes
boom
because he says concepts of time dude
that's the stupidest [ __ ] thing i've
ever said in my life
wow that's [ __ ] good dude i'm
sweating
yes the concepts of time and
three-dimensional space regarded as
fused
in a four-dimensional continuum hey
do i have to put the words in order to
make the sentence
is this one of those dictionaries
the concepts of time and
three-dimensional space regarded as
fused in a four what
regarded as fused enough what are those
words together
regarded as fused in a four-dimensional
continuum
bye bye salam friends
see you next episode
me me after i
bail from guys sir i see myself oh i did
it because i did it twice got it
because i bailed twice once on my
podcast and once by myself
and then in quotes after that the
curvature of space-time
get the [ __ ] out of here dude get out
dude how is this an explanation of space
time
you know what space time is right what
the curvature of space time
oh i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's these are like i knew [ __ ] who
made this [ __ ] dictionary
a dumb guy from new jersey i know these
guys from back home dude
when they they'll say something you'll
be like what's that mean and they'll
just say you know like you know like you
know like and just say the same [ __ ]
thing that they just said
do you know what i'm talking about
you'll be like yeah you've got [ __ ]
all you know you ever ever
[ __ ] tried to make origami it's hard
what's origami you know like [ __ ] you
know like origami you know you got the
thing and it's like [ __ ] origami
these are just a [ __ ] dumb guy from
new jersey made this [ __ ] dictionary
what's space time yeah you know what the
[ __ ] it's like you know you got you know
what i mean it's [ __ ] space time it's
like space time you know what i mean
that's a [ __ ] dumb guy from back home
and this is the definition from oxford
languages british people thought of this
[ __ ]
the concepts of space-time in
three-dimensional space regarded as
fused in
a four-dimensional continuum rather the
curvature of space-time
i just like how am i supposed to know
what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
it's just somebody dumb it down for me
[Music]
man
i decided jeff bezos is doing it all
wrong for my last [ __ ]
horizontal in his [ __ ] the last episode
of
this of this podcast entitled horizontal
in his [ __ ]
i did a [ __ ] i put out a [ __ ] jeff
bezos cliff that
clip that did [ __ ] stupid numbers
i mean bro it was like ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding just
like like like like like subscribe
subscribe like like like like like
ding ding ding bell notification ping
ping ping ping it was just doing
[ __ ] whack job numbers
and i just thought about him a lot since
then dude he's doing it all wrong man
you think it's [ __ ] crazy going to
outer space oh you got
all the money you're gonna go to outer
space
big boy [ __ ] that dude
if i had 131 billion dollars i'm doing
crazy subtle unique [ __ ]
crazy subtle
unique [ __ ]
i'm just [ __ ] buying a chopper
loading it up with sandwiches and just
dropping them off
just in the air dropping them up not
even flying high
just kind of like scraping along the
[ __ ]
the lowest as i can and just dropping
off sandwiches
so low that they're like why didn't even
why didn't he just take a van
just so low just dumping sandwiches out
the kind that no
not many people like to just mortadella
you got to be like a real italian to
like this [ __ ] and i'm still i'm in like
utah
dropping off mortadella sandwiches
there's like what the [ __ ] he doing
that for
because he's stupid subtle because he's
stupid subtle dude
what do you mean well dude he said it
ever since bezos went to the [ __ ]
moon in a cowboy hat and a watch on the
outside of a space suit
dalia decided if you ever was gonna make
131 billion dollars he was just gonna be
stupid subtle about it and that's why
he's got the chopper full of mortadella
and i'm just gonna drop him off hungry
or not here you go hungry or not
and guess what i'm going to do save
world [ __ ] hunger
dude i'm going to save the world if i
have 131 billion dollars
i'm going to save at least american
hunger
and poverty it's gone dude
i'm hiring hitmen for like
[ __ ] uh uh ant eaters
and just tweeting all day about how
shitty ants are
oh well if you ever [ __ ] get bitten
by a bunch of them it really actually
hurts
gone dude expensive hitman the best of
the best
a matter of fact [ __ ] that i'm gonna get
the actual liam neeson
to do it will you play hitman hey jason
stay them liam
nice to meet you love your [ __ ] nose and
hey jason
um so you guys are gonna have to go kill
all the anteaters
here's literally 40 of my
billion dollars have fun i got
sandwiches to toss out talk talk talk
talk talk talk talk talk talk talk talk
talk talk
hey really means business doesn't he
might gave us 20 billion dollars each to
try and kill annie does not even know
where they are
neither do i i did find it odd though
that he was hanging upside down from his
knees off of the [ __ ] thing that
goes below the chopper or whatever the
[ __ ] you call that when you step
into it with a bunch of sandwiches
and he scraped my nose with the blade
um would it be much funnier if i could
know what the [ __ ] the
stand rail thing was called but uh yeah
dude i'm doing it man
i'm gonna unload so many sandwiches that
people are gonna be like all right chris
it's getting weird sandwiches actually
doesn't it's it's hurting much more than
you we it was helpful in the beginning
and it really did save world hunger but
like it's not
the thing sandwiches doesn't fix
everything
[Laughter]
you can't just try to fix all the
world's problems with sandwiches
i'll join the [ __ ] army bro first
line
iron man gear oops can't get me
what the [ __ ] is jeff pesos doing going
a little bit up in space he didn't even
go up into the real space
he went up a little bit and was just
like ah psych and went back down dude
it was like where your girl's like can i
try a little just a piece of my finger
in your butt
after it's old after you're in a
relationship for a long time let's just
try it we haven't tried
and she gets one digit and you're like
no no never mind no never mind no never
mind i don't want that that's what jeff
bezos did
i'll go into space he got up to space
here and then goes wow
and before he was done with wow he was
already back in the [ __ ] atmosphere
[ __ ] that i'm scraping along a 101 in a
chopper tossing out sandwiches
to [ __ ] tesla's driving by
and they're just like dude they're in
the way swerving and i said
[ __ ] you it helps world hunger i'm
stupid subtle if i'm 131 billionaire
guy thinks he's crazy because he goes
out into outer space and laughs and says
hell yes
bro i'm the guy so subscribe to my
patreon
patreon.comcrystalia it helps me
get stupid subtle
i don't know what you guys want from me
but you have it all
everyone out there is spending money
wrong
they made a movie on hulu called jolt
with [ __ ]
beckinsale kate beckinsale or whatever
the [ __ ] and it's just like dude you
want to be like
give it up you just want to be like
give it up the movie what's the movie
about i'll tell you
i'll tell you what it's about a lot of
you probably don't know
the movie's about a woman
who has an anger problem and she's also
because of that anger problem so strong
i don't know you're looking at me like
what chris
i don't know is it a superhero movie or
is it just a movie where she's actually
i don't know
so some kind of genius guy creates a
device that isn't
quite ready yet really
but it's not quite ready yet and it's
not
sold to any markets yet but he hooks her
up
with a [ __ ] goddamn
garage door opener and she every time
she gets so angry she just start beating
the [ __ ] out of people she'll just click
the [ __ ] garage door opener looking
thing
and then she okay
she's out on a date and the guy a guy's
like
i don't know i don't know says some [ __ ]
and she's like
and her eyes dilate and she gets all
pissed and she clicks the garage door
opener and she's like
snaps her back into reality and it's not
a comedy
that's the movie and it's not an adam
sandler movie
it's a kate beckinsale movie about how
dude these movies were i'm sorry but
these movies where women do spin kicks
to [ __ ] like
like guys that look like big thumbs
like you just it just make it a
superhero movie
the movie salt was the worst one where
uh
angelina jolie was just like kicking it
kicking everyone's ass
but not a superhero and you're just like
all right what world are we in
queen latifah's the [ __ ] equalizer
what's going on she's 50 and she's
beating the [ __ ] out of judo champs
sup
um yeah this movie's called jolt
with kate beckinsale
it's i wouldn't even believe it if
[ __ ] a young sly stallone was in it
and that dude can really bang
the [ __ ] show sex life
kristen put it on a little bit and then
on the third episode
the guy shows his [ __ ] you know
it really hit me like a ton of bricks
because i was like
because the guy in the the show is
cheesy
and the guy i don't watch i watched the
first episode and then she sent me a
video of her watching the third episode
where the guy shows his [ __ ] large
[ __ ]
and i was like what are you watching
taken and she i said oh sorry i thought
that was liam neeson's nose and
um and and uh
this guy's naked he turns around the guy
is cheesy in the show
he might be a good actor you never
really know because the whole show is
cheesy so it's the director's fault it's
not the actor's fault
if everybody's good it's the director's
fault if everybody's bad it's the
director's fault you know what i'm
saying
um and uh
so he's just being cheesy and i'm like
cringing
i'm like that guy's so cringy and she's
like he's sexy and i'm like
oh i'm way off all right i don't get it
okay
all right okay this is your deal here
this is your deal let's watch it
let me watch just the part of his [ __ ]
and i was like and she was like
it is so big and i was like let me see
and she shows it to me
the clip and i'm like sweetheart
that's fake and she was like
are you just jealous and i'm like i
don't give a f i mean
if it's real but it's not
it's just not real
and she was like whatever and so we
looked it up and we looked it up
dude and the guy was interviewed about
it and he said a gentleman
never tells and she was like oh so it is
real i was like
dude that means if he's if it's not his
real [ __ ] that is the worst way to
answer that question
because sancy
the mayor of cincinnati you're so
insecure dude
a gentleman never tells it's not my [ __ ]
you know what i mean a gentleman never
tells my [ __ ] is
a lot smaller than that but like you
can't
so i looked it up and then i looked up
another interview and the show confirmed
it was a [ __ ] prosthetic [ __ ]
prosthetic [ __ ] it was a [ __ ] fake
[ __ ] on his real [ __ ]
pronounced in a is real [ __ ]
like dude don't [ __ ] be cute about it
if it's
not your actual ding dong
hey this is the [ __ ]
that sucks because i want to be
interviewed about these things
so i can say the correct things
hey chris we noticed in the show sex
life that you're
uh piece was rather large is it real
and i have rehearsed
for months a musical number
called nope and that's when i just kick
it off
as a matter of fact it's not as a matter
of fact it's not some [ __ ] are big some
[ __ ] are small but this one
this one isn't mine
nope like that's how it ends that's how
it ends
this one isn't a mine [ __ ]
just and i have a company with me like
20
guys that you even recognize them like
just like i think i saw a guy in a
[ __ ] all-state commercial or
something
as one of the third guys in the
classroom is it mine
nope
everyone's doing it all wrong dude
patreon.comcrystalia
you know what i mean don't don't even if
you don't want to i just like it's like
i think being a comedian maybe i ruined
it maybe i should have been
somebody else that i could have done
something and then been this guy do you
know what i mean
because then people be like oh i mean
bro
if let's put it this way
if tom the guy from myspace
did this [ __ ] that i'm talking about
it's over it's over for everyone because
there's that guy now but now they expect
that from me because i'm a funny guy
i need to get more serious i need to
shred this image get more serious and
then come out with the drop in
sandwiches [ __ ]
it's just that i need to get stupid
subtle
space time you know
space time for the [ __ ]
space time so clear um
on the dictionary wow imagine the guy
had to say
every word what is that this is what he
did after this is him after he did it
what he went
space-time what even is that that's what
he did
did somebody explain that to me and then
the next thing he said was never mind
um but yeah dude
whoa it's johnny zone
what else did i want to talk about i
don't know man oh what
okay one fire's gonna text me something
i wonder if it's [ __ ] good or not i
wonder if it's [ __ ]
every time oh he's got a [ __ ] space
time thing here
oh it's with what's-his-name oh a
beautiful oh it's with
oh these two
oh wow dude okay well let's look at it
did you text it on the oh okay here it
is what is space time
with these two well with these two guys
what is space time first of all
couldn't even be more william shatner
than how it started
it's called star talk wow really [ __ ]
ringing that towel dry
you know what i mean
what is space time what is
space time
you know by the way william shatner's
one of those guys that like completely
gets his age wrong by a decade
you know what i mean we're like oh my oh
no i am oh wow
i guess i yeah i said 68 but
you already know the
how could something be so unabashedly
[ __ ]
within one second dude this is unreal
dude
what is space time you already know
you already know you have never
met someone god he comes in so
hot uh
[ __ ] jaleel degrasse tyson what the
[ __ ] his name neal nealgrass tyson
neil grass tyson neil degrasse tyson got
it
neil degrassi tyson um neil degrasse
tyson
and um he comes in so hot you know what
i mean
just born to be a teacher right
it's interesting you should say that
because what
i have already i already have all of the
information
it's interesting that that's something
you'd ask about because i already know
an infinite amount of that particular
subject i just asked you where the milk
was
there are nine gallons of milk in the
refrigerator
and there are many many more gallons
in the grocery store down the street and
beyond that
into the loading docks and beyond that
into the
larger grocery stores that supply the
grocery stores there is an
infinite amount of milk you're just like
reaching in the fridge
okay
what is space time you already know wow
you have never
met someone at a place unless it was
also at a time
you have never met someone okay so
it seems very obvious
what he just said you have never met
someone at a place
wow what did he say hold on i'm going to
go back
also at a time you have never messed up
at a place unless it was also out of
time okay cool you have never met
someone at a time
unless it went okay okay well don't cut
him off
an actor
well don't cut him off some guy
who got lucky
this is a guy who actually has degrees
he's got so many degrees his middle name
is practically degrees
neil degrees tyson
and this guy who [ __ ] acted like he
was on
mars for 140 years
never been on mars but acted like it is
like
i i'll say something now
well wait a minute what happens to a
photon
from 13 billion point 800 hundred
million
years wow so disrespectful and so drunk
what happens to a photog that's 100
billion trillion gadrillion
18.6 fraction of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
years it comes this way
and enters my eye so i can see it
[Laughter]
[Music]
it got drunker
and answers my eyes so we can see it
why where is where's space involved in
that
dude neil degrasse tyson has the way
he's
trying to compute you know what dude you
basically have
the smartest guy and the stupidest guy
talking you know what i mean and i'm not
saying website is the stupidest guy but
pretty much anybody is the stupidest guy
if you're talking about the crosstalk
and he's just like there's
hold on a second where's space and all
that is space in my eye
um it entered your eye at a time
and at a place right here wow that's all
that that's all that's about that is
that's all well once you have formalized
space and time
and know that they're conjoined then you
can make all kinds of fascinating
calculations well what is all that the
trains going
down there i'm walking down the train
i'm walking on the air and the time and
the training of james
what is all that that's all the
consequences of thinking
about space and time how bad are both of
their breaths for real
you can tell because of the room they're
in
as conjoined but it's confusing
not only is it the universe is under no
obligation to make sense to william
shatner
okay no but it's just william shatner's
under the obligation to make sense of
the universe
as is you are doing and and and and why
do
why do i slow down as i approach the
speed of light
it doesn't apply to a photon no you want
to freak out
i don't you know i don't want your head
to explode ready
i'm ready i'm ready okay the faster you
go around
turn around and check this out look the
cosmos say that again the fast
as seen by others right
as you approach the speed of light time
continues to slow down yes
at the speed of light time stops
which means for a photon moving at the
speed of light
when it is absorbed in your retina
it is the same instant it was emitted
at the big bang 14 billion years ago
that's what i thought oh it is guy
oh it is some guy dude
un [ __ ] believable dude
jeff bezos was like hell yes
[Laughter]
dude unbelievable this guy neil degrasse
all right i guess okay okay no the other
ties will do
anything dude he'll come to the [ __ ]
opening of a jack in the box
well i i mean you know what i mean well
i heard you get two
two tacos for 99 cents do you know if
you had four tacos
that that's 1.98 cents and six tacos
i've come here to tell you that there
are billions and billions of tacos
that have been made and billions and
billions that could be
ever made and an infinite amount of hot
sauce
that you can put on those tacos and eat
them
and if you're chris's friend from high
school you can eat 20 of them at a time
it's disgusting it's an infinite amount
of absolute
disgusting disgusting [ __ ]
dude just [ __ ]
he'll go to the opening of a [ __ ] i
swear to god he's been every book
signing that's ever been
dude hello pamela anderson
just every [ __ ] who else has
written a book you know hello fourth guy
from nsync
you wrote a book about your road life
could you inscribe
please in the on the inside flap i
already wrote something there
can you read it billions and billions
yes if you lived forever did you know
that you could make billions and
billions of songs
within sync if they lived forever too
okay bye bye bye bye get it
i've made that joke billions and
billions of times
he's [ __ ] weird just keep signing
i drink loud
um so yeah um
another thing is i gotta go but
i'll save that till next time all right
you guys
you have been really really great and uh
thank you so much for listening
patreon.com
crystalia and uh the merch is just great
you guys gotta be uh gotta be on that
merch we
twitch we're on twitch come on down you
gotta type in flex avenue on twitch
it's a little hidden uh name there for
the pod from the podcast
flex avenue on twitch you watch watch
you come twitch with me
it sounds uh weird to say it that way
but that's how they say it so i'm doing
it like that and it's fun i'm learning
how to play video games and [ __ ]
and also yeah um what else the merch
patreon and uh remember to [ __ ] put a
blazer on that like button
and uh dress up that [ __ ] bell
notification real nice and then also
subscribe dude
subscribe uh it helps the numbers and it
helps me if you like the podcast or
whatever and if you don't like it then
[ __ ] whatever do it but if you do
like it hell yes
hey guys that's it for youtube if you
want to catch the rest of the episode
go on over to patreon which is
patreon.comcrystalia
and watch the rest of it and
if you do we appreciate you thank you
very much there's also other stuff on
patreon
like behind the scenes stuff and uh also
um other episodes that are unlocked
once you become a member um i appreciate
you guys thanks bye
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
stupid subtle's funny though and um
what was the other one smooth idiot is
good too